au paradis avec Michael Jackson c'est le
nom du dernier livre de gonzac Saint-
brce il est avec nous à présent bonsoir
et merci d'être là alors après Henry
François 1er lafillette Léonard de Vinc
j'en passe beaucoup d'autres he des
personnages historiques de Auran vous
vous attaquez à Michael Jackson c'est
assez étonnant oui mais en fait ça
correspond au à la
réalité je suis un des rares êtres
humains qui a passé 12 jours seul avec
Michael Jackson c'était en en 1992 quand
il a voulu faire son voyage en Afrique
le retour aux racines il est il voulait
tourner un film qui s'appelait back to
Africa back to Eden et il m'a demandé de
le rejoindre à Libreville au Gabon vous
vous connaissiez avant non pas du tout
mais il m'avait vu à la télévision
américaine dans le programme le plus
célèbre de la télévision américaine qui
s'appelait Good Morning America sur ABC
où je parlais justement je faisais une
tournée de conférence aux états atsunis
sur la faillette je venais de recevoir
un de littérature deuniversité Kennedy
et je racontais une histoire sur Léonard
et le premier soir où je l'ai vu en
Afrique nous avons dîné ensemble à
Libreville et j'ai dit pourquoi
m'avez-vous choisi et il m'a dit ce mot
américain qui qui dit you musmerize me
vous m'avez subjugué avec votre histoire
et à ce moment-là j'ai commencé à
l'écouter et ça a commencé par une
discussion sur
Michelange et Léonard VO parce que ce
qu'on apprend dans votre livre et ce qui
a surpris un peu tous les commentateurs
c'est que Michael Jackson en fait était
un homme très cultivé par exemple il
avait cette passion pour melange et il
avait demandé la permission au pape
d'être enfermé dans la chapelle six pour
pouvoir contempler les fresques de
Michelange et de temps en temps
d'ailleurs il signait des petits mots
Michelangelo et ça s'est fait ça ou
pasoui fait ça s'est fait il s'est bien
livré à vous alors pendant vous avez eu
une dizaine de jours ensemble voilà
c'est-à-dire que le lendemain de ce
rendez-vous de Libreville nous avons
entré dans l'Afrique profonde nous avons
descendu le fleuve ogoué qui a été
exploré par savounon de braa c'est sur
ce fleuve majestueux immense que le
docteur Schweizer s'était installé à
l'ambaréné et donc j'étais avec Michael
nous avons descendu le fleu au Goué nous
sommes entrés dans la forêt Fang et même
j'ai assisté à des scènes hallucinantes
parce que à un moment on a vu les
pigmets qui sortaient de la forêt en
venant vers Michael qui l'avait reconnu
évidemment en dansant les pigmets
dansaient les pigmets connaissaient
Michael Jackson les pigmet connaissait m
tout le monde dans le monde entier
connait Michael vous savez c'est
extraordinaire les pigm connaissaient
Michael ils sont mis à danser et là j'ai
vu mich qui assis à côté de moi mais ça
je peux pas le faire aussi bien qui
s'est mis à danser en ant lui
assis et après on a on a continué cette
cette descente du fleuve et puis un
matin il y a un hôtel dans la brousse
qui s'appelle le Lony Palace et là un
matin 7h du matin je sors de ma chambre
sur le balcon et qu'est-ce que je vois
de profil à deux balcons plus loin
Michael avec derrière avec les brumes
bleuté qui montaient avec les PL
rougeoyant et quelques heures après je
dit tu sais c'était comme une peinture
et là il me dit fais attention ce qui
est peint ce n'est pas ce que tu vois ce
que tu vois ce n'est pas ce qui est
peint l'artiste en général peint ce
qu'il y a entre le motif et lui et il
commence à me parler de la peinture de
Poussin puis ensuite il me parle de la
peinture de deux gars mais je lui dit
mais Michael qui t'a appris tout ça
parce que entre son enfance où il est
sur scène dès l'âge de 5 ans où est-ce
qu'il a eu le temps et il me répond tout
ça c'est grâce à Diana je dis mais
quelle Diana c'est Diana Ros qui m'a
initié à la peinture alors dans votre
livre on apprend tout c petites
anecdotes he comme vous avez commencé à
le faire on on se demande aussi c'est
c'est un truc qui a beaucoup une chose
qui a beaucoup plus aux fans on le voit
déjà sur les blogs
Internet vous vous le présentez comme un
homme simple en définitif facile
d'approche comment vous le définiriez
vous qui avez passé beaucoup de temps
avec lui il était
indéfinissable parce que parfois il
était j'ai écrit parfois tu étais comme
un fantôme tu étais encore là et
cependant déjà absent parfois tu étais
lointain et c'était ta façon de
t'approcher et comme les princes de ce
monde à qui on a donné le nom d'icône tu
étais gracieux dans ta démarche sur le
tapis roulant du temps mais il avait
plein d' des graisses de getté de
drôlerie et puis quelquefois quand vous
étiez à côté de lui il s'absentait en
restant là et pris par ailleurs tout
d'un coup il se met il revenait posait
des questions par exemple à un moment on
descend le fleuve et il me dit est-ce
que c'est vrai que Louis X a perdu tous
ses cheveux à l'âge de 20 ans j'ai oui
c'est vrai parce que effectivement Louis
XIV a une typhoïde mais j'ai dit mais
comment toi tu le sait et vous verrez
dans le livre que il avait cette passion
de la culture française la passion des
châteaux que quand son fils est né est
né donc le premier Michael junior il a
voulu acheter un château en France et à
ce moment-là il a commencé il faisait
les tournées européennes mais il
revenait toujours à Paris et il a
commencé à se balader dans un van au
vitres fumé et personne n'a pensé à
regarder
l'immatriculation de ce van au vitres
fumé c pas compliqué à comprendre il y
avait trois lettres bad alors toutes ces
anecdotes dans votre livre à trouver
dans dans toutes les librairies on peut
aussi vous rencontrer dès demain matin à
looche en sé de signature et plus tard à
Paris voilà je je vous invite tous à
vous êtes tous invités à la séance de
signature demain matin à loche à la
Maison de la Presse de 9h à midi et puis
si vous êtes à Paris mardi prochain qui
sera le mardi 11 mai je vous invite à
venir me rejoindre au fouets 99 avenue
des Champs-Élysées pour une autre
signature en hommage à Michael Jackson
mon zacrce merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur notre plateau ce soir nous présenter
ce livre étonnant au paradis avec
Michael Jackson quant à moi je vous
souhaite un très bon weekend on se
retrouve lundi soir pour votre prochain
rendez-vous avec l'actualité
tourangel